foreign
[Music]
this week we have again all kinds of
exciting Hollywood news for you that
includes Spider-Man across the
spider-verse first details of season 5
of stranger things a holiday movie with
Dwayne Johnson and Chris Evans as well
as a high quality film adaptation of the
Gears of War franchise we've also
gathered exciting news about the darkest
Star Wars series yet the John Wick
spin-off and an Indiana Jones series so
we hope you enjoy our new video
the Gears of War franchise from
Microsoft has been around for over 15
years in the meantime the popular first
part from 2006 has led to two prequels
and four sequels the latest installment
titled gears 5 was released in 2019
there have been attempts to make a movie
out of the game series in the past but
these never went beyond the planning
stage back in 2007 new line Cinema
secured the rights to an adaptation with
the most recent attempt being made in
2019 but Netflix has just acquired the
rights to the game series and is now
planning something big right on time for
the 16th anniversary of the franchise
two projects are scheduled to go into
production first a movie adaptation is
to be made followed by an animated
series aimed at adults moreover Netflix
is open to the possibility of following
up the two projects with other films and
series official announcements about the
cast have yet to be made however no less
a figure than Dwayne Johnson could take
on the lead role he teased at the
beginning of the year that a video game
adaptation would be announced this year
that he was very much looking forward to
and that he himself had played for years
the talk was about Xbox games which
would apply to Gears of War another
candidate who was currently being
considered is Drax actor Dave Batista
who has also expressed his excitement
about a film adaptation in the past is
there anyone else that you can think of
who would be a perfect match for the
leading role let us know in the comments
exactly which parts of the storyline
will be adapted into the film is not
known yet but we hope to have more news
soon
next summer we can look forward to
Indiana Jones 5 which will probably be
the last time starring Harrison Ford in
his legendary role anyone who thought
that the franchise would be over for
good after that may well be wrong as
variety informs a Disney plus series is
already being worked upon behind the
scenes which could merely be the
beginning of a revived franchise still
if Ford is unavailable to star in the
series the question remains who will
follow in his footsteps is this possibly
going to be a prequel or will it even
start Indy's goddaughter Helena who is
embodied by Phoebe Waller bridge in the
new film in the 1990s there was already
a series called the Young Indiana Jones
Chronicles at that time a prequel was
also created from it showing the young
Indie in different stages of his life
that rather suggests that the upcoming
series will focus on a new character
instead of producing a similar series
twice before we start speculating about
further details we must first wait for
the feature film which is scheduled for
release on June 30th 2023 in all
likelihood the film will provide more
clues as to the direction the series
will take
Marvel's 2018 Spider-Man into the
spider-verse was a fan and critics
favorite and has been awaiting for an
equivalent sequel for over four years
now next year this will finally happen
and the bar is set high in the first
part we already saw a lot of different
Spider-Man successfully fighting many
villains alongside Miles Morales in the
sequel there should be even more
additions on both the side of the
superheroes and the villains at the
moment there are rumors about two
popular Spider-Man cast members one of
them is Yuri lowenthal he is the actor
behind Peter Parker in the popular
PlayStation game Spider-Man from 2018.
in the game you get to meet many
characters from the Spider-Man universe
including Auto Octavius podcast host J
Jonah Jameson and villains Electro Rhino
Scorpion and vulture since the game has
nothing to do with the MCU their
respective characters also have no
connection to their movie counterparts
and thus have a life of their own as the
comic circus reports none other than Tom
Holland will be the second newcomer in
the past there has been much speculation
about an appearance by Spider-Man actors
Tom Holland Toby McGuire and Andrew
Garfield if the article is to be trusted
at least one of the three will make it
into the sequel rumors regarding McGuire
and Garfield are persistent and
Holland's involvement further reinforces
them however there is no concrete
evidence yet moreover the signing of
Daniel Kalua as Spider Punk has been
revealed at Marvel the character has not
yet had a long tradition as he first
appeared in the comics in 2015 while it
has been known for a while that spider
Punk will be a part of the Spider-Man we
didn't know that the nope actor would be
dubbing the character Spider-Man across
the spider-verse will hit theaters on
June 2nd 2023 and we hope to soon see a
first trailer that may reveal more what
do you think of Tom Holland Daniel Kalua
and Yuri lowenthal joining the cast of
Spider-Man in the upcoming animated film
and which Spider-Man or Spider-Woman do
you feel should absolutely be in the
movie let us know in the comments down
below
U.S magazine collider exclusively
reported on the upcoming ballerina film
This Week shooting started earlier this
month in the autumnal city of Prague and
it looks like the John Wick spin-off
will include two key characters from the
movie series in fact Megastar Keanu
Reeves will make it a point to play his
iconic role as John Wick in the spin-off
how big his part will be is still
unclear however it will certainly not be
so big that he steals the show from
leading actress Anna diarmus apart from
him another famous actor will make an
appearance in the series namely Ian
McShane as Continental manager Winston
other than that few details are known
yet Anna De armas will play a young
female assassin who seeks revenge for
her family Under World director Len
Wiseman is set to direct with the
screenplay coming from John Wick
rewriter Shea Hatton a release date for
the spin-off has not been announced so
far but at the very least the waiting
time until John Wick chapter 4 on March
24 2023 is kept within reasonable limits
with stranger things The Duffer Brothers
achieved unparalleled success not only
did it revive the 80s but it has also
become an integral part of today's pop
culture on Monday in keeping with the
annual stranger things day we got some
initial information about the upcoming
fifth season on the official Twitter the
front page of the first episode script
can be seen the episode is titled the
crawl and has since fueled lots of
speculation despite the fact that only
the title and nothing else is known for
those who haven't watched season 4 yet
there is now an increased risk of
spoilers clever fans suspect that the
crawl is a reference to Metallica's song
master puppets which features the line
come crawling faster since this song was
played by Eddie shortly before his death
in the upside down many suspect that the
fan favorite will return in season 5.
other theories refer to Max Crawling
Back To Life after her coma another
theory is that The Duffer Brothers
simply included a Dungeons and Dragons
reference in the crawl named after the
famous dungeon crawls unfortunately
there is no release date for season 5 of
stranger things yet but we will keep you
updated
suspect that the released title of the
first episode has a deeper significance
and may hint at Eddie's return or do you
rather believe that this is a deliberate
misleading of the people in charge just
to see how the fans react be sure to let
us know your thoughts in the comments
Black Adam has barely been in theaters
for a couple of days and the 50 year old
Dwayne Johnson is already busy promoting
his next film this one for once is not
about fast cars overly muscular
superheroes but about Christmas more
specifically he stars in an action
holiday movie suitable for the entire
family titled red one in keeping with
the 2022 Christmas season which has long
since begun there was now also a first
image showing Johnson together with his
colleague Chris Evans a festively
decorated toy store can be spotted in
the background as deadline reports
shooting is said to have begun in recent
days besides Johnson and Evans a number
of well-known actors have made it into
the cast of the film including Kill Bill
vol 1 actress Lucy Liu Jumanji actress
Bonnie Hunt and Whiplash star JK Simmons
the Christmas Blockbuster will be
directed by Jumanji director Jake kazden
with the screenplay being written by
fast and furious author Chris Morgan the
movie will be available on Amazon Prime
Video in time for the Christmas season
at the end of 2023 and it can be assumed
that Amazon will commission further
releases should the movie be a streaming
success so we can't wait to see how the
movie performs next year who knows maybe
we'll witness the start of a whole new
franchise
the Star Wars series The acolyte has
been in the works for quite a while now
for the first time there is a large
number of announcements from Disney sign
above all the news about the cast is
voluminous with nine actors confirmed
all at once among them are the hate U
give Star Amanda Stenberg squid game
lead actor Lee Jong Jae The Last Ship
star Jody Turner Smith and Matrix
actress Carrie Anne moss in terms of
story the series is set in the age of
the high Republic and therefore in a
time with a powerful Jedi Order but
highly destructive Wars against the sip
it is meant to resemble a mystery
thriller that deals equally with the
Sith and the dark side of the force the
focus will likely be on Stenberg as a
former Padawan who is accompanied by her
Jedi Master Lee Jong Jae along with
pictures of the new cast the official
Twitter account also published a first
image from behind the scenes one thing
already seems clear the series will most
likely be the gloomiest one yet from the
Star Wars franchise and will be set in
dark secrets and mysterious Powers the
showrunner and direct of the pilot
episode of the acolyte is Leslie
Headland who is known as the creator of
sleeping with other people for example
when exactly the series will be
available on Disney plus is currently
unclear since production has only just
begun it will probably take some time
all right now you're back up to date in
case you're interested to know more
about movies from the science fiction
genre check out our new original episode
on villanueva's Dune part 2 where we
cover everything you need to know about
the upcoming sequel thanks for watching
and we'll see you next week
laughs
[Music]